Bayern's strange plan to return CR 7 to Europe All for a bet as heard by
hooligans already Several media from Germany report that CR 7 could return to
Europe and specifically to Bayern But let's go on the side Gambeteros the
midfielder to Ben Saintún specialist in Bayern issues revealed that a
mysterious mail arrived at Bayern's offices The matter offer them a strange
deal for Cristiano Ronaldo to wear Bayern's colors The Munich have suffered
without a center forward and Cristiano seems to have one more bullet In Europe
The marriage does not look so unlikely but let's go back to the plan Marcus
John is the businessman behind this idea I will have offered to pay for the
transfer of the bug His company would invest in the pass and earn from what the
transfer generates in terms of marketing and merchandise And so everyone would
win Bayern would not spend so much Cristiano would have one more lap to Europe
and Marcus would gain from the dividends.
Everything sounds beautiful but the truth is that
this looks more false than Infantino's love for soccer.
To begin with Cristiano is happy...
In Arabia his Arab adventure is beginning...
On the other hand,
Bayern already refused to have the bug in the past and
finally the money that would be needed to achieve that move
would be something astronomical for the Arabs to release the bug.
We would all love Cristiano's return to Europe,
but with this plan the truth looks painfully impossible.